hey guys it's justine and today we have
a new episode of our podcast that's
coming out
it's with me and my sister it's called
same brain i will put all of the links
in the description where you guys can
check that out but this video is going
to be kind of a recap of some of the
highlights
talking about wwdc the ps4 the new xbox
animal crossing food video games and
pretty much everything in between but
first i want to say a huge thank you to
dbrand for sponsoring this video i've
had this
skin on my 16 inch macbook for a very
long time and they also just came out
with some for the new 13 inch macbook
so i just put this one on as well and i
am so happy with how they turned out
they just come in these little sheets
just like this they even have track pad
covers as well so if you really want to
completely deck out your computers
they do they do have them for so i even
have
some on my air pods i have some of my
controller
and they even made this one
this was a parody of the animal crossing
nintendo switch there's one thing that i
do love
is dbrand definitely knows how to troll
i'll put a link in the description if
you guys want to check out
more really awesome skins from dbrand
let me know what your favorite one is i
think you probably know
what my favorite is it's obvious
so now we need to set up for the podcast
i thought that since we shot that first
episode of the podcast that we would
have a whole new setup well
we don't and this time i'm going to be
recording jenna's audio off of
the 16 inch macbook and i'm gonna be
recording my audio off of the 13 and why
i like this is because i can put this
one aside and i can just be on my little
computer
and since we are doing a video component
to this this isn't completely
covering me up like the 16 inch like i
still can't get over how big the 16 inch
macbook is
it's wild
[Music]
i have to take my contacts out i'd say
my contacts out because i can't wear
glasses with contacts
one two three the same brain podcast
we should probably practice that a
little bit at least we were like the
same shirt
that was an accident
i've never owned a shirt like this why
are you wearing it today
i bet it's the same brand target hey
we're going to be talking about a bunch
of things there's been a lot happening
in the tech world playstation 4 had
their announcements
wwdc is coming up playstation did i say
four did i say four okay it's okay
oh my god do you know how many times
i've said playstation 4 yes
every single time uh wwdc i'm very
excited it's
a whole new wwdc it's a virtual
experience and what's interesting about
it is normally tickets are like fifteen
hundred dollars for developers to attend
but it's it's free i'm getting discord
notifications oh we have a discord now
so much has happened since our last
podcast since the first one
was many many months ago this is great
if you want to join the discord
um it'll be somewhere you just search
for it and you'll
you'll find there'll be a link somewhere
my favorite rumor is
the new imac it's supposed to be what do
they say it's like the ipad
pro design thinner bezels similar to the
pro display xdr well that makes sense
because it's like you know they gave you
a little tease with the ipad another
like bam i back
scared you scared myself uh the new uh
arm-based mac plans justine
what do we think about that jenna's
really just teeing me up what do we
think about it so this is interesting
because they're
planned to shift they're going to be
providing some insights and efforts to
transition away
from intel chips made in the house which
makes sense first of all when you're
using intel chips or any other types of
chips
you know they're not building them
themselves so they'll be able to really
dial in
and make something that works exactly
how it should integrate with like a
macbook so i'm really excited to see
how that all kind of works out so giving
this information up front to developers
allows them to start working on this for
the future we're saying like the first
uh
armbase max probably won't be coming
until 2021 which is actually almost here
isn't that crazy half of 2020 is gone
okay so well let's see ios 14.
this is also exciting because we get to
find out more information about what
is you know in the works for ios 14. so
there's already an
early test version that was leaked apps
on the home screen
may get a list view apple is working on
a fitness app that will let users
download guided workout videos on iphone
ipad
apple tv and apple watch it's crazy too
i wonder if people
like now that they've figured out how to
work out at home or like maybe they
bought equipment like will they go back
to a gym
yeah or now our company's going to be
starting to shift more into
marketing towards at home which i've
seen a lot of different fitness things
pop up over the past couple of months
some that i've been following for a
while third-party wallpaper packs we're
going back to wwdc apple may allow
developers to create wallpaper options
that iphone that would be able to be
installed through the wallpaper section
jenna skipped to the end because she
wants me to hurry up and stop talking
about it's a little
warm in here i'm not done yet messages
may get at mentions in group chats i
like that
yeah our friend ed he's really tough
sometimes you get a hold of like
ed we're outside and then like 20
minutes later we're like edward outside
if we can at ed because we're in so many
group chats i feel like i don't really
talk to just one single person anymore
it's usually like i talk to you in like
17 different
yeah oh a feature for retracting eye
messages
oh okay okay okay oh okay we're moving
on here
this is i'm excited about watch os seven
so i'm just gonna scroll down here to go
to the blood oxygen
tracking that's what i was excited about
me too so according to a code found in
the leaked version of ios 14
apple is working on watchos 7 and apple
watch series 6 feature that will allow
the apple watch
to detect blood oxygen levels okay so we
talked about that
we did talk about what happened i'm
still not done talking about wwdc
because i'm very interested to see how
they're going to do this whole
virtual thing i mean they stream it live
all the time so like how is it really
going to be
that different but they have like a good
point
that's a really good point the point
that jenna has made is very good just
like
there's people in the audience and now
there's not people in the audience this
is a great point that jenna has made
not like but that's not all because
there's lots of courses and things like
that so not just the actual keynote
so there's like a few days of events and
learning so it's gonna be streamed live
and it's just not gonna have people
there and you watch it on the internet
so okay not that weird anyway moving
along you're right you're right you're
[Music]
right